لكن حتى لو تم تبليغ كل العقبات ووصل
السلاح الى اوكرانيا ستبقى معدله اخرى يا
طاهر سنتعرف عليها معك
هذه المعضله تتعلق بنتائج الانتخابات
النصفيه
ومطالبه الجمهوريين بالتدقيق في الاسلحه
المصدره لاوكرانيا ومراقبتها الهامش
الضئيل للاغلبيه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب
دفعهم للتحذير من ان اداره الرئيس جوبيدا
عليها توقع اشراف اشد صرامه على المساعده
العسكريه المكثفه التي قدمتها الولايات
المتحده لاوكرانيا كما ان الضغط يتزايد
لتكثيف عمليات تعقب الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
وهو مقامه به اداره بادن تحسبا لمثل هذه
المطالب من الجمهوريين
متابعه ايضا في الاسابيع الاخيره اعلنت
الاداره عن جهودها لتتبع شحنات الاسلحه
كما حدد كل من وزاره الخارجيه والبنتاجون
الخطط بما في ذلك المزيد من عمليات
التفتيش والتدريب للاوكرانيين والتي تهدف
الى منع وقوع الاسلحه الامريكيه في الايدي
الخطا
واشنطن بوست نقلت عن محللين قولهم ان معظم
الاطياف السياسيه في واشنطن تتفق على ان
الضغط نحو المزيد من الرقابه امر جيد لكن
على ان لا يتحول الى مجال للتنازع السياسي
بين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين ذكرت
الصحيفه بل ذكرت بحديث زعيم الاقليه
الجمهوريه كذبتي عن ان الولايات المتحده
لا ينبغي ان تعطي لاوكرانيا شكا على بياض
كما طلبت ايضا النائبه مارجورين
باجراء تدقيق في برنامج المساعدات بعدما
طلب بيض من الكونجرس تخصيصا 37 ملي دولار
لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وعلى عكس الشكوك من جانب الحزب الجمهوري
يحاول بعض اعضاء الكونغرس من الديمقراطيين
التوفيق بين وجهتي نظر النائب ديمقراطي عن
ضرائب الامريكيين يحق لهم معرفه اوجه صرف
اموالهم سواء كانت الاموال الموجهه
لاوكرانيه او لغيرها نوه النائب الى قانون
مراقبه تصدير الاسلحه الذي يفرض على
الاداره تقديم تاكيدا معقول بان متلقي
المساعده العسكريه يستخدمون الاسلحه للغرض
المقصود منها وبحسب شروط تحددها الولايات
المتحده
العضو او العضو في لجنه القوات المسلحه
بمجلس النواب دفع باتجاه ضروري
بالمراجعه والتحقيق والتفتيش على كل ما
يتعلق بجهود البنتاجون لدعم اوكرانيا
واصفا الامر بالضروري واعتبر النائب ان
الاخطاء وسوء توزيع الامدادات امر وارد في
اي حرب مكرا
بانه من المحتمل ان توجد قيود مستقبليه
على نطاق المساعده التي يمكن ان توفرها
الولايات المتحده لكن بعضا من المشرعين
ومسؤولين بانتاج جون قالوا انه توجد
القليل من الاسباب الملموسه للقلق خاصه
وان اوكرانيا تقدم بشكل دوري تقارير تتحدث
عن كيفيه استخدام المساعده العسكريه
الامريكيه
هؤلاء المسؤولون يرون في المبادره
الاوكرانيه امرا مهما فيما يخص تتبع
الاسلحه الامريكيه الوارده اليها وتحديدا
الاسلحه الاكبر حجما وعيارا وليس الاسلحه
الصغيره التي تتسبب او تتسرب الى السوق
السوداء
له بعمليات تفتيش على الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
متى هو حيثما تسمح الظروف الامنيه قال
المتحدث باسم الوزاره
ليست بالقرب من خطوط المواجهه في الحرب
رافضا الادلاء بمزيد من التفاصيل حول
برنامج التفتيش واشنط بوست اشاره الى ان
رصد مسار الاسلحه يتم تعذيذه في حالات
خاصه عندما تحتوي الاسلحه المعنيه على
التكنولوجيا حساسه خاصه كصواريخ ستينجر
والدفاعات الجويه واجهزه الرؤيه الليليه
[موسيقى]